Hey everyone.  We've covered issues between divisions, but we want to focus on how those divisions work independently and interdependently.
Let's dive into it.
We are back here at NexTech and we're going to be launching our new product, the Nova Pro.
This is NexTech's most ambitious product yet.
Everything was already set.
Engineering had finalized the specs, Marketing was executing a multi million dollar campaign.
Sales had pre ordered agreements with key distributors, and supply chains have locked in sourcing contracts.
And still the launch was delayed by six weeks.
So what went wrong?
Each function, each division did its job, but no one owned the outcome.
In effect, NexTech created a structural failure rooted in functional silos.
Organizational units such as marketing, Engineering or operations that focus on optimizing local performance, often with limited coordination across the departments.
Functional silos are efficient at developing depth of expertise, standardizing routines and optimizing local performance.
They enable scale by breaking work in the manageable replica units.
This is a model drawn from industrial era principles of division of labor.
However, this efficiency comes at a cost.
As silos grow in autonomy, they also fragment accountability, meaning that no single actor is responsible for end to end outcomes.
And each unit becomes focused on hitting its own performance metrics, even if those metrics are misaligned with the firm's broader strategic plan.
This results in a paradox.
Each function succeeds independently, but strategy fails collectively.
What looks like local optimization at the departmental level often translates to global sub optimization for the organization as a whole.
Silos aren't bad by design.
Division of labor is a pretty good thing.
Each unit gains depth, expertise and autonomy.
People get clear goals and leaders get measurable outcomes.
But silos have another side.
They obscure independence, interdependencies.
They shift focus from customers to internal metrics.
And they struggle when work becomes or what requires integration, like launching a complex time sensitive project.
So as coordination demands rise, silo based structures create coordination cost.
This is the time, effort and negotiation required to align decisions across autonomous units.
In our example here, Next tech is experiencing increased coordination costs and this is causing structural misalignment.
That is where the company isn't aligning goals across itself.
NexTech needs to fix this problem.
And one way to do so is create ownership of connection points.  Points.
According to organizational theorist Jay Galbraith, when interdependence increases, firms must evolve their structure to support lateral coordination.
Cross functional mechanisms like project teams, liaison roles and shared metrics that bridge silos and reduce execution risk.
At NexTech, Nova Pro's delays weren't due to poor execution.
They were due to structural misalignment each term.
Each team did its part, but no one was responsible for the whole.
That's where lateral coordination becomes a necessity.
NexTech can create project leaders to sync timeliness or vendor approvals.
Product teams create shared ownership, where success is defined as launch success and not departmental success or liaison roles to flag misalignments early and prevent launch delays.
This will help formalize collaboration, assign accountability and and create measurable outcomes.
Let's take a look at what happened.
Engineering signed off on the prototype, didn't check with compliance.
Procurement sourced a new chip, but the vendor had failed to pass an audit.
Marketing booked ad buys before customer support even knew what was launching.
Each team claimed success, but the product failed to ship on time.
This breakdown illustrates the absence of horizontal accountability.
This is a critical gap in many traditional organizations.
Most firms are built on vertical structures.
Each department is measured by its own performance.
Engineering by technical delivery, Marketing by campaign reach and operations by efficiency.
And these structures are excellent for specialization.
But they also assume values created within functions.
When no one is explicitly responsible for coordinating across silos, I.e.
aligning goals, timing, resources and decisions that even the best strategies collapse in the gaps between teams.
This is what we call an execution gap.
That is the space between strategic intent and operational reality.
Vertical hierarchies define who does what by function or department.
But in modern organizations, outcomes such as launching a product or delivering a customer experience cuts across those functions.
Without horizontal accountability, no one is responsible for integrating the work and execution fails at the seams.
Value is increasingly created across functions such as product development, fulfillment and service.
But when accountability is confined to silos, teams will optimize for their own metrics and not the end to end result.
Horizontal accountability ensures someone is responsible for the full flow of value, not just the isolated contributions.
To fix this, NexTech moved to the M form structure.
This is a multi divisional form of organization.
Each major product, like Nova Pro becomes a semi autonomous business unit.
These units had a general manager with full profit and loss responsibility.
Embedded leads from marketing, engineering, ops and finance, and shared accountability for product performance.
Moving away from the departmental metrics now, our teams aren't organized around their own functions.
Instead, they're organized around outcomes for the organization.
An informed firm decentralizes operational decisions to divisions, each aligned with a product, geography or customer, while keeping strategy and capital allocation centralized at the corporate level.
In an inform organization, the company is divided into semi autonomous units, each responsible for a distinct product line, geography or customer segment.
These divisions have their own leadership teams and are given decision rights over Day to day operations, including production, marketing, local budgeting.
Critically, they also take profit and loss responsibility, meaning each unit is accountable for its own financial outcomes.
At the same time, corporate headquarters retain centralized control over strategic functions such as such as capital allocation, portfolio management, long range planning and brand and policy oversight.
This dual structure works because it mirrors how value is created in diversified firms.
Let's look at each focus.
Each division can focus on a specific market or product, leading to deeper expertise and faster decision making.
Accountability Profit and loss ownership drives accountability at the divisional level, so results are no longer diluted or obscured by conglomerate reporting.
Strategic oversight headquarters can act like an internal investor evaluating divisional performance and allocating capital to where it creates the most value and scalability.
The structure can accommodate growth.
New divisions can be added as the business diversifies without overwhelming central leadership.
Now we're going to move from our service level agreements to shared success for next Tech.
Redefining the structure was just the beginning.
It also redefined how teams were measured.
They replaced siloed metrics like marketing impressions and procurement cross procurement cost savings with shared key performance indicators such as time to market, gross margin by product, net promoter score and post launch product reliability.
Now the Nova Pro team won or they lost together.
But keep in mind, structure alone is not enough.
Just because teams report to the same GM doesn't mean they're truly collaborating.
As long as marketing is measured on impressions and engineering on specs, they won't naturally align.
Hierarchy can enforce structure, but only shared goals and mutual accountability enforce collaboration.
Shared key performance indicators equal shared ownership metrics like time to market and post launch defect rate force teams to coordinate, negotiate trade offs and care about the end to end experience.
When teams are jointly measured on outcomes like time to market product reliability, success depends on how well they work together, not just how well they perform individually.
This shifts the focus from functional excellence to cross functional execution.
And it reflects the theory accountability must match value creation.
Organizational theorists like Galbraith and Chandler showed that performance systems only work when they mirror how value is actually produced.
If teams collaborate to deliver results, the metrics and accountability must span those same boundaries.
If outcome span functions, the KPIs must too.
So here are a few questions for you to consider when thinking about your own organization.
What metrics in your organization reinforce silos?
How would your team behavior change if you shared key performance indicators across functions?
And where are you using service level agreements when you should be using outcome metrics?
For example, it responds to help desk tickets within 24 hours versus employee satisfaction with IT support improved by 30%.
How do you change this?
And how do you measure it?
Let's finish up some key takeaways.
Functional silos optimize depth, but ignore flow.
Silos build expertise and efficiency with functions, but they often overlook how work moves across boundaries.
The result is local excellence, but systemic friction, especially during cross functional execution.
Cross functional work requires shared ownership.
When teams contribute to a common goal, isolated accountability breaks down.
Shared KPIs and joint decision rights create the conditions for true collaboration and end to end performance.
Inform structures align teams with products, not just processes.
By organizing around products or business lines, informed firms give teams full visibility and control over the value they create.
This structural focus enables autonomy while preserving strategic alignment.
Interdependence rises, so must integration, as work becomes more interconnected.
Coordination cannot rely on hierarchy alone.
Firms must add lateral mechanisms like shared metrics.
Project teams cross functional governance to keep pace with complexity.
And lastly, strategy doesn't fail at conception, it fails at coordination.
Great strategies often fall apart in execution because no one is responsible for connecting the pieces.
Coordination gaps, not bad plans are the silent killers of enterprise performance.  And that's it.
Hope you've enjoyed it.